they drop down to a lower level there
has to be a stairwell down
foreign
[Music]
i think we just got buzzed
i understand and i'm doing the best that
i can just please wait
sir i've got the navy the japanese the
russians all breathing down my neck
demanding to know why we've got a c-17
circling a disputed island
don't tell them anything just yet
[Music]
ah just in time
tell me you know
madeleine matild
they're my uh
yes fun
do we have any royal naval vessels in
the immediate vicinity
uh yes why we are going to need an
immediate strike on this location this
whole island
it's a manufacturing plant for heracles
we don't have clearance for missile
strikes to do it
bond there's something else you should
know several unidentified ships are
headed your way
they're coming after heracles how far
out uh 20 minutes
queue
patch me through
let's go
it's going to get very cold out there
so
i want you to have this
keep your warm
i have to finish this
for us
i know
[Music]
[Music]
this might come in handy
thank you
by the time we get to the scene a lot's
been revealed we discover that madeleine
has a child and we discover that this
child was born shortly after her and
bond were together
right when he's reunited with madeline
and meets this child she is abducted by
the villain in this film that loots
versafine and bond is then on a mission
to get them back
it's really the toughest assignment for
bond because
not only is he going there to save the
world but he's going there to save the
woman he loves
and the child he's just found out that
he has
bond goes halfway around the world to
this disputed island and infiltrates
this fortress this kind of classic
villain's lair which we've never seen in
daniel craig's run and has a
head-to-head scene with soften that
results in him escaping
with the child and now
bond has to try and find them and in
trying to find them he finds madeline
and then madeleine and bond together are
looking
for matild when they're looking around
for her they find her under the table
and they meet up with nomi and go to the
boat and have a farewell
at that point and he's going back to do
what bond does best
which is to raise hell in the place
in looking for a location for the poison
island we kind of liked the mixture of
it not necessarily being in japan not
necessarily being in russia but sort of
this
um vaguely uh historical island with a
legacy
there's an actual island or it's a
peninsula of fairy islands that is sort
of the exterior
shots of the island that we shot but
then
the interior of the layer and the
the entire sort of
architecture of the layer is uh is all
built on stage i had a pretty clear idea
of
in my mind what that space could look
like mark tildesley the production
designer and i spent a bit of time you
know first honing in on
the the brutalism and the concrete uh
forms and how then with leanness how
light would play into that
and one of the things we got really
excited about was this
almost like black and white film this
the use of
light
in limitations so like where light is
really only hitting in very specific
non-linear
shapes within the set and how bond then
can use the shadows as a means to get in
and get out the layer sequence is quite
long and it's it's got a lot of
choreography to it that is the challenge
with something like that is what is the
geography of of this place and and
how how do these bits all fit together
so i think that it's a you know great
achievement to make that whole thing so
compelling part of the jenga tower
of shooting is
as much as something like this would
seem like it has infinite resources it
doesn't you know we had very
finite restrictions on how much we had
and how much we could build especially
there wasn't just wasn't enough
space to build every set we needed so we
had to build sets and then take them
apart and then build new sets in the
same location
in order to achieve all these different
sequences i remember when we built on
double seven stage this whole like lab
with all the light sticks
in the water and the pink people working
there
um and we come into that set and i'm
like mark it's incredible you built this
it's like you had no time and you made
this huge just like 50 foot tall set
with i guess it's the biggest stages in
the world
and when i come in there i'm like wow
that's amazing carrie comes in there
he's like
can it be a little longer
you always wanted like a little longer a
little bigger a little taller
it's like it goes very well with like
the whole idea of the film is that you
just wanted to be as rich as possible
yeah just push it push everything yeah
push a little bit yeah yeah we'd met
carrie before
a long time ago and had wanted to sort
of work with him so it was really great
having a guy come on who
is also a writer what was great about
that is that he immediately came on
board and he started kind of making the
film his own he wanted to push the
envelope as far as the emotion was
concerned you know it was it was good to
go down that road when we brought leonis
on they really had a great vision about
what the film should look like
how the locations would influence the
film and he just got straight into it he
was remarkable the first time bond sees
madeleine
is actually in the water of italy
and she's in the water of um of a sunset
that is like glimmering sunlight and
she's sort of almost like an angel
and then at the end when he sees her the
last time which is
uh in that sub pen with the inflatable
she goes out into the hole and we just
let that exposure be completely
overexposed so that she just disappears
into the light again
and it's somewhat like symbolic like
religiously symbolic not that i'm
religious but like visually it is uh a
symbolic thing that he he he sort of
sees her first time in the film that way
and she sees her the last time in the
film that way there's that golden light
as as they go off and that's sort of
like
you know that's going to be his last
memory it's sort of unreal because it's
so perfect but it's the way he's looking
at them isn't it and
you know that moment when he says i'll
just be a minute
it kind of is your inkling that maybe
this isn't going to work out well i mean
there was a whole scene of dialogue i
remember that we had to shoot and uh we
couldn't get it to work so i went let's
just cut it i mean i had confidence in
the moment
it felt like we were explaining the
scene and we didn't need to explain the
scene the scene was i have to do this
i'll come and get you and hers was i
know you have to do this
i i i believe you but that was the
reason i felt it was important to just
be about
non-verbal don't explain it allow the
audience to sort of start feeling things
maybe there's a sense of foreboding
maybe there's something going on and the
fact is that they're just like i love
you i love you i'm coming back i promise
but i've got to do this. leah sadou is
just magnificent
she is a wonderful wonderful actress
because she brings so much truth to
everything and i think you can really
relate to her i think it's absolutely
brilliant that um
the women in this movie play such a
central role they're so important to
driving you know the story forward they
are badass um and
fully involved in the action and they
are not damsels in distresses at all
that need to be rescued by anyone and
they are formidable
strong powerful confident capable women
and i love that image being projected
shawna walked into the room
having had done a play for barbara but
just just in the interview process i was
really um
i really enjoyed her energy and then
when we had her kind of like read a
scene and then do some physical training
with our stunt guys everything she did
she excelled at and it felt very much
like nomi's character like nobody's
gonna be the one who gets straight a's
and you know perfect marks and firsts
and all those different things like high
achiever
and she very much kind of just was that
in real life
i've got them
this might come in handy
thank you i think what rami malek did
you know with this character with his
intelligence and his sort of
you know the way his his mind works and
how we as an audience get to see how his
mind works through his acting uh was the
perfect guy to play this role i cannot
imagine anyone else doing it and rami's
intensity
reads very clearly
on screen especially when he
is triggered
it's not like we're shooting in ms6
office and then on the stage kind of at
the same time we're shooting them almost
months apart
and things are shifting screenplay
shifting
but kind of miraculously the order at
which it was scripted
it's the same order ended up within the
edit i mean the only kind of
tenant
i had in my mind was momentum
everything's starting to build the
momentum it's like okay we've got the
kid we've got the white let's get him to
safety okay we got to stop this thing
and meanwhile
tensions are building heat's been
turning up underneath and i remember
we'd been doing studio mode
in um the mi6 office which was the first
scenes we shot
and we switched to handheld then you
remember that when you're handheld you
can get right in there yeah there's
something about being able to to to
position yourself in a way that you
can't when you're on a dolly you're you
know sticks
without forcing the actor to go in there
and you're dealing with you know we have
a child so you have someone who's never
acted before mixed with someone who's
got incredible amount of experience and
putting them in a scene together and you
know you move the camera exactly where
it needs to go to
to communicate you know what's happening
there in that moment for example when
madeline finds little girl under the
table and they are reunited that relief
they all must feel and yet
bond feeling reap but also see he's like
this is a family this could be my family
but there's more to do we have to get
out of here
having those multiple
uh uh
emotions taking place at the same time
always adds richness and it's more fun
for the actors to be able to play those
things and of course to have a talented
actor like daniel have all those things
happen on his face and to be able to
register that the audience is a separate
joy in this film he actually is allowed
to
do comedy but in a really great way and
i think that line where he says this is
uh
matilda this is madeline
my family but he doesn't you know he
just does it
doesn't say the lord say
it's kind of comedy but it's also like
also yeah i mean that's coming straight
after
him seeing uh matilda
and madeleine having found her says i
love you and bond is standing there and
he's looking at the child and he's kind
of
thinking the same thing
but he's got his professional job
you know he's got to get them out so
it's that mixture
of him being in completely uncharted
waters of having to deal with his
emotions
whilst trying to still be the
professional uh agent
daniel's done a very good job i think in
all of the films establishing a new kind
of bond is a big break i think from the
more macho
bond that we'd had in previous
iterations
[Music]
we should go
it's cute do you read me
i'm in double o seven it's q and you
have you know actors like ben who
has no one to work with you know he's by
himself on the c17 set yeah you know
having to act with
the first ad reading lines from off
camera you know
and like blank computer screenings
because the graphics will be put in
later when you're an actor it's so
helpful to have the energy of another
actor there to build attention he had a
really difficult job of playing all
these things plus a very emotional
ending as well um
i'm not gonna make it
what
we have
him finally meeting his end in a great
very spectacular effect that you created
yeah we had to do justice to daniel's
last moment um i think it was a
combination we did a three huge
explosions out on salisbury plain they
were extraordinarily large
and then charlie noble and the visually
his visual effects team tweaked them to
that to fit them into the you know the
scene as it were and then composite them
into daniel's last shot but
very emotional moment i have to say even
though i knew what was going to happen i
still still got me
it gets me every time i yeah yeah and
the music the score as well was just so
powerful well had simmer is just a
genius when the orchestra came and and
they started playing this song that we
had just written it was so unbelievable
and so surreal you know the way that
hans like
used our
melody
the piano
like that was the first sort of
foundation block and then especially the
the piece that stuck out to me was the
piece that plays during the last
15 minutes of the film it's an emotional
enough thing to watch without music but
the the score underneath it is so
stunning
you know throughout the film we have um
we have themes and we have different
sort of moods and looks for different
set pieces and um in this case the
entire island
that sequence is shot from late
afternoon to sunset i love that idea
that um
also that you have a very brutalist
style complex that is so cold but that
we treated it with
with the most romantic and sort of
melancholic
feel by lighting it with the late sun
and make it sort of romantic even though
it's um it's obviously a really
sort of terrifying there's like a tragic
element to this this chapter of the
story you have this
heroic mission to not only save the
world but to you know protect
uh his love and his child at the same
time
by doing that it's inevitably going to
lead to his demise
she does have your eyes
i know
they are bond's family in terms of
office professional family and they've
been with him and you know supporting
him and um
doing everything they can to kind of
provide him with the tools that he needs
to do his work and so they all have a
very personal relationship with bond in
the story and of course towards the end
is truly heartbreaking when they
all come to realize the situation he's
in they try to help him and of course
they can't
so it's a very very emotional
group
we're chasing more time
if we only had more time
[Music]
you have all the time in the world